it was driving the main funding at
one time, I said already
participating in special military operations
in the Donbass in Ukraine assisting the
people's republics of the Donbass acting
courageously competently effectively and
efficiently
using the most modern types of
weapons with unique
unparalleled characteristics as far as
remote sensing of the earth
means a major project  for the production and
launch of special spacecraft have
combined for this purpose the scientific and industrial
potential of Russia and the leading enterprises of
Belarus,
which have always been famous since Soviet
times for their competencies in the
production of high-precision equipment for the
most complex optoelectronic and
radio engineering systems.
to the state an
independent spacewalk in the very
near future, workers and specialists of the
company and enterprises of Belarus
on  get the opportunity to participate in the
development of the city of Tsarkovski and the Vostochny Cosmodrome, the
goals are absolutely understandable,
ignoble, I myself started, after all, I
draw your attention to my first very
first public statement, an appeal to the
country armed today, I’m right at the
sound of the goal, the main goal is to help people on
vasek, this is an obvious fact, this is
not Nazism  unfortunately, it has become a fact of
life of a
fairly large party close to us
, this is an obvious thing, it was
inevitably a matter of time,
what we are doing helping people save
from here with me so much, on the other
hand, we
will take measures to ensure the security
of Russia itself,
it is obvious that we have another choice  it
wasn’t just a project, and we are not going to
isolate
rigidly isolate
anyone in the modern world, and even such a
huge one, because Russia is definitely
impossible, so we will work with
those of our partners who want to
interact
in modern conditions just within the framework of
this external pressure  I, we have
new opportunities to
use all our
potential to support each other to
ensure the unconditional provision of
our breeding, including in such
high-tech
industries as space, I caught myself
thinking, you know, it’s important that I came here you
don’t feel sanctions
do you want to drink or honestly all our review
domestic people work thousands of people
thousands of people at the facility are busy thank
you for inviting us to
participate in this construction he
will definitely accept your offer we will
offer you interesting options